In Miami, Rick Kamla reporting that Shaquille O'Neal has announced his retirement from the NBA.
19 seasons, he's 39 years old, and he's done.
One of the greatest players in NBA history is hanging 'em up.
The list of accomplishments for Shaquille O'Neal is seemingly endless,...
...a 15 - time All-Star,...
...won four championships, three with the LA Lakers, a three-peat,...
...one with the Miami Heat back in 2006,...
...three - time Finals MVP, all with the Lakers,...
...1999 to 2000 NBA MVP.
His all-time ranks in regular season play, fifth in scoring,...
...12th in rebounding, seventh in blocks and second in field goal percentage.
Shaquille O'Neal's final game,...
...it was Game Four against the Miami Heat.
And for Shaquille O'Neal in that game, four minutes, zero points, and two fouls.
At seven o'clock we'll come up with Game Time.
We'll have full comprehensive coverage of the Shaquille O'Neal retirement and much, much more.
We will see you then.